[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN GABLE: Hi, everyone.
It's great to see you here.
Hope you had a great lunch.
My name is Ben Gable.
I'm a game developer and
developer advocate here
at Google.
I work with game
developers to help them
make great games on Android.
And today, I'm
here to talk to you
all about a topic that I find
very personally interesting,
and that is adapting Android
games beyond the phone.
So it wasn't too many years
ago that when somebody
said mobile gaming
or Android gaming,
you'd think of a
device like this.
Everybody knows what this is.
It's a phone.
So you've got a touch screen.
You've got an accelerometer.
Gyro controls.
Resolution and aspect
ratio are pretty
standard across all of them.
But I'm here today to tell you
guys that Android gaming is not
just phones anymore.
And the Android ecosystem
is constantly evolving.
And Android now not
only runs on phones,
but things like Chromebooks,
tablets, desktop extension
technologies like Samsung
decks, and coming very soon,
the world of foldables.
So tons of OEMs are working
on foldable devices.
You might have heard of
the Samsung Galaxy Fold.
So as game developers,
you guys need
to start considering
what kinds of devices
that your players are going to
be experiencing your game on.
It could be a phone
in portrait mode.
It could be a Chromebook or
DeX device with a keyboard
a mouse attached.
Or pretty soon, it
could be a foldable
with two screens that are
changing the resolutions when
they open up the device.
So I want to get a quick show
of hands of how many of you have
actually thought
about this problem
and maybe have a
game that you've
optimized for a device that's
not just the mobile phone.
Show of hands.
OK.
Not too many.
So that's good.
Hopefully, you guys
learn a lot today then.
And this is really important
because as game developers,
we want to provide the
best possible gaming
experience for our players
no matter what device they
happen to be playing it on.
So as gameplay
continues to evolve--
not only devices are
evolving, but we're seeing
the gameplay evolve as well.
So mobile gaming isn't just
hyper-casual one button one
touch games anymore.
We're seeing these
gameplay designs
that mirrors something
you'd expect on
like a PC or a console with
longer playing sessions, more
advanced controls.
And so people like
me and many others
want to play these types of
games on Android in a way
that I would expect to play
it maybe at home on a console,
or on a PC with a
keyboard and mouse.
And not only that,
but maybe I want
to see it on a bigger,
more beautiful screen.
I want to avoid the hand claw
of playing my favorite MMORPG
for many hours on end.
And it's not just
about providing
the best possible experience,
it's also about reach.
One of the key themes of
the gaming keynote this year
at I/O, which I don't
if you guys saw it,
was about reach and
reaching more players.
And so gamers-- the
number one thing
that we hear from our end
users are that they want
to play games on these devices.
And our friends at
Gameloft actually
found this out firsthand.
So they have a game, Asphalt 8.
And they saw that people were
playing it on a Chromebook.
And so they went in
and we worked with them
to optimize the controls
and some of the UI elements
to suit these larger screens.
And what they found is that
after they optimized it,
they saw a 6x increase in daily
active users and a 9x increase
in revenue, just for the
Chrome OS version of the app,
not against mobile.
So this just goes
to show that players
want to play these games
on these other devices.
And so it's really important.
There is a desire to play across
all these different classes
of devices.
So let's talk going
over overview of what
each of these classes are.
So starting off
with Chromebooks.
So you might know
Chromebooks as laptops.
But the operating
system Chrome OS
now runs on many different
kinds of devices.
So we've got all-in-one
desktop boxes.
You've got detachables.
You've got tablets now,
like the Pixel Slate.
There's a variety of
inputs usually associated
with Chrome OS.
But the primary input devices
are keyboard and touchpad.
And as you know or may not
know, Android runs inside
of a container on Chrome OS.
So the full version of Android
is running inside there.
And to your game,
it's essentially
running on an Android device.
It's just that it happens to be
connected to a larger display
device, and maybe it
has inputs attached.
So what we found for
a lot of developers
is that 90% of their
game is probably
running on a Chrome
OS device right
now if you go and download it.
And the last 10% is just
really easy small tweaks
to make sure it's fully
optimized for that hardware.
And Chromebooks are growing.
So we saw that reach 26%
market share last year.
And year over year, the market
is growing 77% for Chromebooks
according to NPD.
So Google's put a lot of effort
into growing the Chromebook
and Chrome OS line.
And gamers are continuing
to buy these devices.
And they want to play games.
Tablets.
Tablets have been around
since Android Honeycomb.
A longtime.
And you now you've got a
wide variety of tablets.
Everything from the Pixel
Slate, which is more,
I would say, high-end, to
more affordable devices
and other premium tablets
like the Galaxy Tab S4.
And tablets remain
a huge portion
of what we think of as
this mobile gaming space.
So according to NPD, last year,
19% of all active mobile gamers
were playing on
an Android tablet.
And that's across
all mobile platforms.
So as you can see, there's a
large group of players there
that are active and
want to play games.
Third, desktop
extension technologies.
So more and more we're
seeing mobile devices,
like a lot of Samsung
devices, come with technology
that allows you to connect
it to a larger display,
to connect things like
a keyboard and mouse.
And actually it is
not just the Android
OS, with you've got
a full screen app,
but it actually simulates
a multi-window environment
where your game window can be
resized and dragged around.
So it's much more like
a desktop experience
than what you'd expect
from Android on the phone.
And as I said before, coming
very soon are foldables.
So we've got tons
of OEMs that we
know are working on
foldable devices.
And there's going to be
a lot of interesting use
cases with the smaller
outer screen opening up
to the larger inner screen.
So this is something
that you guys
are gonna have think about
as well, coming very soon.
Now, I realize the
words "new platform"
are kind of scary to a
lot of game developers.
And there's already
a lot of challenge
on supporting all of the device
fragmentation on Android.
But what I want
to stress here is
that this is all still Android.
And by following the Android
best practices, which
I'll talk about
today, you're going
to get a great baseline
experience across all
these different devices.
Now, there are obviously
more targeted things
you can do for specific
devices and form factors.
But today, I'm
just going to focus
on the stuff in the middle
there, the best practices.
They're going to give you the
best overall compatibility,
no matter which device
your players are
going to be playing on.
And you can do this
all with one APK.
And it's possible.
You don't have to
do multiple APKs.
You don't have to try to
fit everything into one APK
and stay under some size limit.
This is all possible
with one APK.
And it starts with
changing your mindset.
I get it.
You're in development.
There's features
that have to ship,
deadlines that have to be hit,
patches that have to be pushed.
And it's very easy
for developers
to start thinking
about devices as,
I've got to fix this
bug for these devices,
I've got to improve
performance for these devices.
But as engineers, we're taught
to be adaptive, and anticipate
changes, and make sure we handle
a wide variety of scenarios.
So I realize in the fast
pace of game development,
it can be very hard
to think about that.
But for supporting
all these devices,
the key thing I
want to stress is
to anticipate changes
and be adaptive.
And, for example, you might
change your assumptions
that you're not just playing
on a small screen with a set
resolution.
You could be playing on a laptop
or a larger display screen
with a much different
aspect ratio and resolution.
You might have a touchscreen.
You might not.
You might have a
controller attached,
or keyboard and mouse.
You might have accelerometer.
You might have a gyro
available for input.
And you might be playing on
something from a low-end phone
all the way up to a
gaming-capable high-performance
Chromebook, for example.
So it's really
important to get rid
of the mindset of
you're just building
one APK for a
certain set of device
with a certain set
of assumptions,
and build an APK that can
adapt and change no matter what
environment it's running in.
So luckily in Android,
if you're not aware,
there is this concept of
configuration changes, which
is the method by which
Android tells your game
and your activity about
things that have changed
with the environment
you're running in
and that you might care
about and adapt to.
So there's lots of different
configuration change events
that are getting thrown around
in Android when things happen.
For example, if a keyboard
gets attached or detached,
if the orientation of the
screen changes, or maybe
the screen size resolution
changes as well.
And so by default,
what's going to happen
is the Android OS
is sitting there.
And it's listening for any of
these configuration changes.
And what it does
by default is, it
will ask you to maybe
save your game's state.
It will give you some
method to save custom data.
It's going to restart
your activity.
And then it's going to restart
it and give you back the data
that you saved to try
to reinstance and go
back to where you were at.
However, for a lot of
resource-heavy applications,
and especially games,
we do not recommend
that you let the Android
OS do this for you
because, in some cases, you
can get lots of configuration
change events, even across a
couple of different frames.
So for resource-heavy heavy
games, restarting the activity
and reallocating
all your resources
is going to slow
down the system.
It's going to slow
down your game.
And it's not going to give
that seamless experience
that you want when
players are switching
between different
configurations.
So there's another way in which
you can handle configuration
changes, and that's through
handling them yourself
in your code.
So in your manifest,
you can simply
declare all these different
configuration changes
that you want to
handle yourself.
And then in your
activity, instead
of restarting your
activity, it's
going to invoke on
configuration changed.
And it's going to give
you the new configuration
that you're running in.
So now you could do
things like scale your UI
or your OpenGL content to
match the new resolution.
You can toggle
your control scheme
to adapt to some input device
that was attached or detached,
et cetera, et cetera.
And so there's lots of
different configuration changes
that you can listen for.
But what I've done is I've boil
it down into three key areas
that you guys should be
thinking about and looking
at when it comes to handling
these different types
of configuration changes.
And they are screen
considerations,
input considerations,
and how to build your APK
and set it up in a
way that it's going
to be very adaptable across
all these different devices.
Now, different devices mean that
there are certain configuration
changes that will happen more
often, or maybe more important
to handle and be aware of.
But again, for the greatest
baseline compatibility,
which is what we suggest
everybody goes for,
you're going to have
to look at all of them.
So that's a quick overview
on configuration changes.
Now let's jump into, what are
some of the considerations
you have around dealing with
screen configuration changes
while you're building
out your game?
So you've got a game.
And on devices like
Chromebooks and Samsung DeX,
by default, your game
is going to be launched
in a windowed environment.
So this means that you
have a game window.
It can be dynamically resized
to different aspect ratios
and resolutions.
And this is by
default. So this is
much different than
what you'd expect
happening on a mobile device
when your game gets launched.
And now coming soon on
devices like foldables,
you've actually got a much
different aspect ratio
on the outer screen.
And when you open up, the
player can open up the foldable
at any point in time, and your
resolution and aspect ratio
are going to change yet again.
So you guys have to be
set up to handle that.
Now, each one of these
cases, as I said,
is going to fire off an
onConfigurationChanged event.
So again, the key all comes back
to handle these configuration
changes and make sure that
your game is set up to do so.
So in this example,
I've set up that I
want to handle screen size
and orientation configuration
changes.
So now, if somebody
is playing my game
and either one of
those events happens,
I'm going to get a callback
to my onConfigurationChanged.
And now I can scale my UI
to match the new resolution.
I can adjust my orientation.
I can adjust my input areas.
Because if your screen
resolution changes,
now your touch input areas
are going to change as well.
So it's a pretty
powerful function
to be able to do whatever you
need to do that suits your game
and how you've built
it to be able to handle
all these different things that
might be happening at any point
during gameplay.
Now, if your game
is always intended
to be run in full screen, which
for a lot of mobile developers
and Android developers,
they expect this.
There is a way to lock
your game to full screen.
So in your manifest,
you can just
simply declare resizable
activity equals false.
And this will by default launch
your game in a full screen.
And it will not be
resizable at all.
However, we don't
recommend that you do this.
Only as a last
resort, or if you're
trying to fix some
bugs in the meantime.
Because what it does is it
limits the user experience
on these windowed
kind of environments.
So for example,
now they can't have
like a chat application
open, or YouTube,
or something like that.
And actually, on
mobile devices as well,
it prevents it from
running in split view mode.
So as you'll see
a little bit later
in the deck when I
talk about foldables,
this becomes even more of
a limitation for the user
if you don't allow your
game to be the resizable.
Orientation.
So you should be thinking
about the default
orientation of the
device you're running on.
So on phones, it's portrait.
But many other
devices, it's not.
It's landscape.
And actually, a lot of these
devices now we're seeing
are convertibles.
So Pixelbooks and
other Chromebooks
are a great example,
where they can
switch from a clamshell
landscape orientation
to now a portrait tablet mode.
So it's really
important to make sure
that if you haven't
already, specify
the sensor orientations
that your game supports.
And so what this
is going to do is
it's going to tell the OS what
orientations your game runs in.
And you won't get
into weird situations
where if somebody
flips the device
into a different orientation,
your game flips upside down,
or it gets into some weird
orientation change loop.
And if you're
handling it in code,
make sure you're using
Display.getRotation,
as this is going to get you the
actual rotation of the device.
But be aware that the rotation
might be swapped to the default
values depending on what
the default hardware
orientation is.
So just be aware of that.
Now, another thing with
foldables to think about now
is aspect ratio becomes
really important.
So as you can see there
on the outer screen,
the aspect ratio is much longer.
It's 21 9 to be exact.
And so for supporting full
screen on that outer screen,
you have three options
to make sure your game is
going to handle this correctly.
The first is to target
SDK 26 and above,
which for a lot of you,
if you're pushing updates,
this is required
by Google Play now.
So that's the first option.
Make sure you also set your
resizable activity as true.
So again, letting the system
resize your application
as it needs to be done.
And now, if neither of
those are an option for you,
what you have to do then
is specify a max aspect
ratio inside your manifest.
So this needs to be set
underneath the application tag.
2.4 will handle aspect
ratios up to 21 9.
So that ensures
that your game will
run on these different
aspect ratios.
And of course, when
you do this, make
sure that your UI and
everything behaves
the way you would expect it
to on these different aspect
ratios.
Now, I talked a little
bit about split view.
And on foldables,
there's this new feature
in Android P called
multi-resume.
So with these larger screens,
there is this interesting use
case that now you can have
multiple activities up
and running on the
screen at the same time.
Now by default, as of
Android P and earlier,
if you had two activities
running in split view mode,
only the one that was
last interacted with
is going to be running
in the onResume state.
Everything else would either be
an onStart or onPaused, which
doesn't make a lot of sense
because then you can't really
play a game or have a chat
like application update
if you're not
interacting with it.
So now in P, there's this new
feature called multi-resume,
which means that if both the
OEM and the game developer--
or application developer--
opt into this feature,
now every top level
visible activity is going
to be in the onResume state.
So essentially, this means that
users can finally multitask
on these larger screens.
And they can have the game
open with a chat application
or whatever.
So this, again, is
really important
that you're tie it back to make
sure your game does support use
cases like this.
Because as more and more players
pick up foldable devices,
they're going to expect that
something like this works.
It will be a
disappointment to them
if they download your
game, and they find out
they can't utilize it.
Now, to support multi-resume,
it's super easy.
Again, you just go
in your manifest,
and you add this
metadata in there.
So now if both the OEM and you
have opted into multi-resume,
you're going to support it.
And for devices that don't
yet support multi-resume,
it'll run exactly as it
does by default where
only the last activity that
the user interacted with
will be running in
the onResume state.
So it's really
easy to support it.
And if the device
does not support it,
there's no risk there for you.
Now in general, with more
pixels comes more flexibility
as well with HUD and UI design.
So if your players are
playing on a larger screen,
consider what UI elements
they can add, expand, change,
or adapt to suit that display.
So they also tend to sit farther
away from the screen the larger
that screen is.
So make sure all your
text and elements
are readable and
identifiable as well.
And our friends over at Klei,
the makers of Don't Starve,
did a great job of handling
this, where they actually
give you the option of
removing the virtual joystick
and the touch buttons
on the screen.
And you can also scale
the size of the UI and HUD
to match what you would
expect for whatever device you
happen to be playing on.
So it's a great
example of giving users
the choice of setting up to
optimize for a certain screen
size.
So now let's talk about input.
And input, I'm going to
throw up this line again
because input is a very--
this is where this
comes into play.
Because input is very volatile.
At any point during
your gameplay,
a user can attach
an input device.
They could remove
And so it really
comes down to, again,
trying to anticipate
that you're going
to get some kind of
input hardware event,
and being adaptive
to what that is.
And by being
adaptive, that really
means try to anticipate
what the user might intend.
So obviously, if somebody
attaches a controller
in the middle of
gameplay, they probably
want to use that controller.
So your game should just
naturally switch over to it.
And not only doing that,
but allowing users to choose
what kind of input methods
that they want to use.
So you might find that there's
a bunch of different input
methods that are attached to the
device your game is running on,
you want to give players the
choice of picking which one.
So it all comes down, again, to
it's not just the touch screen.
There could be a lot of
other things attached
to it as well that the
users want to play with.
So again, ties back to
the configuration changes.
So here in this
example, I'm setting up
that I want to handle keyboard
being attached or detached,
and also if the keyboard
becomes unusable.
So that's that keyboard
hidden flag right there.
And where that comes into play
is on things like Pixelbooks,
you might have a keyboard
that's available in the hardware
when you're in clamshell
mode, but when a user flips it
into the tablet, the
keyboard is in the backside
and is no longer usable.
So it's important
to also not forget
about the keyboard hidden
configuration events as well.
And now, a way to kind of
approach this volatility of all
these different input methods--
what I've done here
is, as an example,
trying to detect
maybe a game startup,
or during my
onConfigurationChanged loop,
trying to detect all the
devices that are available
for me to control the game.
So I can use input
manager here to loop
through all the
hardware and figure out
what input devices are attached
to this particular device.
And then once I do that, I can
loop through and maybe check
out and see, is there
a mouse attached?
Is there a keyboard attached?
Is the keyboard usable?
And it comes down
to trying to assess
the state of all the input
devices that are currently
available.
And then in this case, if I
detect that I have a mouse,
and I have a keyboard,
and it's usable,
I now switch my control
scheme over to desktop mode.
So I've got WASD, and maybe
mouse to click or something
like that.
So it comes down to
trying to figure out
what's available to you and
what the user might want to use.
And this also ties in with,
what is your gameplay?
So obviously for a first person
shooter type of gameplay,
mouse control is going
to be more important.
If you've got a
third person camera,
maybe use the mouse
to control that,
or you're using WASD to
control the player movement.
So adapt it for
your game as well.
Different gameplay, different
things are going to make sense.
So Asphalt 9.
Gameloft did a great job
of this with Asphalt 9
and Asphalt 8 where basically
at any point during gameplay
if somebody attaches a new input
device like a game controller,
it just seamlessly
pauses the game,
it pops up a new dialog that
shows the user, OK, here's
all the buttons you need to
press for a actual controller.
And throughout the
entire game, they
change all of their
text and visual textures
to show that new input method,
whatever the primary input
method is.
And on top of that,
they also let the users
go into the options
at any point in time
and adjust what control
method they want to use.
So it's a great example.
And I recommend you
check it out of, again,
being adaptive and
anticipating those changes.
And for a lot of you
that make mobile games,
you might not think that
keyboard support makes a lot
of sense for your type of game.
And I would ask
you, maybe though,
to consider that when you
add in keyboard support,
you improve the
accessibility of your game.
So you could do things
like skill key bindings,
WASD for character
movement, menu navigation.
If you really
wanted to get fancy,
you could also let players
map specific buttons
to in-game actions,
so they can set it up
to play exactly how they want.
And don't forget
about mouse capture.
So this was added in Android
O, this mouse capture API.
And it's very, very frustrating
when I boot up a first person
shooter or something else,
and I try to use the mouse,
and it does not work.
So it's really easy to just
request pointer capture.
It locks the cursor to
the center of the screen.
You can get your motion
vectors from your mouse.
And then if you
want at some point,
you can release pointer
capture to go back
to standard mouse control.
So it really, really
makes a huge difference
and makes games
infinitely more playable
when you're playing on something
like a Pixelbook in laptop mode
if you can use the
mouse, and it works.
Game controllers.
Now, game controllers
have been around
for a long time on Android.
And there's been
game controller APIs
with varying levels
of game controller
support from developers.
So there's more and more
game controllers that
are being launched for Android.
And as we see these new devices
that are running Android,
there's a growing
interest in players
being able to pick up some kind
of Bluetooth-enabled controller
sitting on their couch and
playing on a larger display
device.
So considering adding
in game controller
support because it's becoming
more and more prevalent.
So we've talked about
screen considerations.
And we've talked about
input considerations.
Now I want to talk about
some general considerations
around building and setting
up your APK in a way
to make sure it supports all
these various devices running
Android.
So first off, you should
review your permissions
that you're asking for.
And not only your permissions,
but your features.
So not all features are
supported across all
these different devices.
And if you're blindly asking
for a certain feature that's
not available, somebody
is going to come along
in the Play Store excited
to play your game,
they're going to
try to download it,
and it's going to
say this game is not
supported on this device,
which is not a win for anybody.
So what I recommend you do is
you list them as not required
in your manifests, unless
you absolutely need them.
And then in your
code, just check
for the availability at runtime
and if they're not available,
just handle it
gracefully if you can.
So again, being adaptive to
the device you're running on.
So good examples
of features that
are not supported on
all of these devices
are things like GPS, SMS.
Even something like
the back facing camera
is not present in a
lot of Chromebooks.
So if you ask for these or
need them for certain features,
you won't be able to
download on those devices.
Now, you should also
consider the hardware profile
that your game
could be running on.
So I know a lot
of game developers
either have some kind of
quality profiles set up
for different device classes
or performance levels,
and some developers
actually implement
a kind of runtime automatic
quality control detection
system that's seeing
what your frame rate is
and trying to adjust things
like draw count and stuff
like that on the fly.
It's really important to either
test the automatic quality
control software you
might be running,
or to add quality
profiles set up
for these new range of devices.
So if you've got a
gaming-focused Chromebook that
comes out, or something like
that that has a lot more CPU
and GPU performance
potential, try
to create profiles or make
sure your game handles
a case of running on
these higher-end systems
and looks great on
these larger screens.
Additionally, try to provide
an x86 build if you can.
So a lot of Chrome OS
devices are Intel only.
And while your ARM
binaries will still run,
you might incur some
overhead with the instruction
translation that's happening.
So try to provide an x86
version of your native libraries
if you can.
I'm going to talk
about Android App
Bundles in a little bit,
which is a great tool
to make this a lot easier
to support, rather than just
inside your APK along
with your ARM binaries.
And if you're going for the
most graphical performance,
lots of these devices
now support Vulkan.
And Vulkan has
reached a point where
we're seeing lots of gains from
developers that are choosing
to use it, in terms of
maximizing their battery
performance, and their
graphical performance as well.
So consider moving
over to Vulkan
if you're really going for that
high-fidelity type gameplay.
And finally, test across
all these devices.
So add test cases
that cover things
like resizing,
minimizing, maximizing,
switching from
the smaller screen
to the larger inner screen.
I know that you might not
have all these devices,
or have the resources
available to have
the actual physical
devices the test on.
So use things like the
Android or Chrome OS emulator
to test on.
Samsung has released
a foldable emulator
that works on Android
Studio as well.
So just try to boot
up your game in one
of those, if you don't
have the actual device,
and see how it behaves.
And doing that,
you're going to be
able to get a great idea of
if you have any major problems
right out of the gate.
Also, you can use something
like Firebase Test Lab
to help automate the
process as well, which
has all these different kinds
of devices inside of it.
And in the spirit of
using the tools that
are available for these
different devices,
Chrome OS specifically
has a performance tool
they just announced here at
I/O that if you are looking
at developing for Chrome
OS, I highly recommend
you take a look at it.
It's kind of like
systrace, if you
use that, where it shows
you how the desktop is being
composited, when the memory
swapping is occurring,
CPU, GPU frequencies, and so on.
So highly recommend
you use the tools
available for the specific
devices if they exist.
And if there's a tool
that you guys would
like to see that's not
available, let us know somehow.
And we will do our best to
try to accommodate that.
Now, I mentioned
Android App Bundles.
And for those of you--
to tie it back to
what I said about,
you can do this with one APK.
Well, you could do
it with one APK,
or you could do with
one Android App Bundle.
And Android App
Bundles are essentially
a new way of distribution on
the Google Play Store, where
it saves you from having
to manage multiple APKs,
or trying to fit everything
inside of a single APK,
and staying underneath
the Play Store size
requirements for your base APK.
So instead of uploading an
APK to Google Play, what
you do is you put everything,
all your native libraries,
all your different screen
density resolution assets,
all your localization
files into an App Bundle.
And you upload that
to Google Play.
And now what Google
Play is going
to do is when somebody
comes along on, let's say,
high resolution x86
device, it's going
to generate and
sign and give them
an optimized APK
that only contains
the x86 and high
resolution assets.
So they get a smaller
download size.
And they don't get
all this extra stuff
that they don't need
to run the game.
Now, some of you might be
aware of on the Play Store
that there's a hundred
megabyte limit for your APK.
If you go over that amount, you
have to use expansion files.
If you use App
Bundles, that limit
is actually increased
to 150 megabytes.
So we're really
recommending-- this
is what we feel is the future of
distribution on the Play Store
and Android in general.
So we've been recommending to
all developers, and especially
game developers that
have a lot of assets,
and different sets of
libraries, we recommend you
guys try to switch
over to App Bundles
if you can as
quickly as possible.
And luckily, it's
pretty easy to do.
I've talked about that.
If you're using Unity
2018.3 and above,
you can simply just choose to
build an App Bundle instead
of an APK.
Or if you're using Android
Studio 3.2 and above,
you can simply, again, choose
to build an App Bundle instead
of an APK.
And then once you
build that App Bundle,
you just upload it straight
to the Google Play Store.
Now if you have a custom
build pipeline or something
like that, you can
use a great tool
called Bundletool to generate
an App Bundle from the command
line.
And another useful
feature of Bundletool
is that not only will it
generate an App Bundle for you
to use, it will also let
you generate test APKs
from that App Bundle.
So let's say you
build your App Bundle
and now you can
generate specific APKs
for different device
configurations
and hand that off
to your QA team
or to your automated
testing solution
such that you get all
the benefits of this App
Bundle, smaller
download sizes, but you
don't have any of the
overhead of trying
to also generate APKs to fit
into your existing testing
processes.
So it's a great tool.
And I recommend you
guys check it out.
OK.
So we've talked about a
lot different things today.
And obviously, there's a lot
more we could talk about.
But what I really want
to stress to you guys,
again, is that Android gaming
is not just phones anymore.
Players are experiencing,
whether you know about it
or not, or like it
or not, they are
experiencing your game across
a wide variety of devices.
And by following some of these
best practices that I've talked
about-- so thinking
about the screen, input,
setting up your APK
in a smart way--
you're going to cover all
these additional use cases
and get the best possible gaming
experience for your players
no matter what device they
happen to be playing on.
And if there's one thing
that you take away--
we talked a lot about
different technical points.
I want to stress that
if you start off just
by changing your mindset
about what kind of device
you're building for, in the
sense that you're not making
any assumptions about
its capabilities,
or what input devices, or input
methods it might have attached
to it, just change your mindset
and try to build something
that's adaptive is possible,
either in your next game
engine or your next game that
you happen to be building.
And if you start off just by
spending a little bit of time
thinking about these
additional use cases,
it's going to make
your life a lot easier,
and you're already going to
get 99% of the way there.
So I wanted to call out if
you're very interested in maybe
having your game
looked at and seeing
how it might function on
these different devices
or any other technical
questions you might have,
we're actually doing game
reviews in a garage back there.
So I highly recommend you
guys stop by and check it out.
You can just go through
the doors over there
in the back corner.
There's a walk-up desk.
Either myself or one of
my esteemed colleagues
can sit down and
talk with you guys
about any kind of technical
issues you might be having.
And that's it.
I hope you guys found this talk
informational and exciting.
And I hope a lot
more of you consider
all these different
devices as you continue
to build out your games.
And thank you so much.
And I hope you have a great
rest of the I/O. Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]